it starts here first if you're not
mentally there to say okay this is
possible this is possibly being
irrational by the situation you already
defeated but also know you can't be
fearful of something this one's set you
back you know I'm not afraid to tell my
flaws and other things I'm insecure
about we all have insecurities and it's
so and doing that and putting that in
music people relate to that a little bit
more than you know somebody's pointing a
finger we're trying to tell you what to
do my music I've never been that you
know he's always inviting the listeners
to things I've learned the audience of
the things I learned and also accent
questions the problems done concerned
about or I don't know how to fix these
social consciousness and awareness thing
like it brings all walks of life
together from a jump I always said to
myself I do an adventurer any type of
business outside of art and the culture
of hip-hop and I had to have for
creative control and having that control
you know always want to have something
that represents more than just a price
tag and spend money and how cool it
looks someday actually has a connection
of saying with my music so when doing
the first shoe I did with the red-blue
is made a connection and I felt that's
always needing anything you know talking
about everything stems from rap and
perspective you know so move forward my
business ventures you know it always had
that same type of aesthetic when jay-z
first had Rockefeller you know he got
his clothing brand machine brand puffed
with all this business ventures you know
with liquor and trade with the
technology these some of the things that
you know they said hip our last one year
now you have individuals that
billionaires
their thoughts in their biggest dreams
and create a process of making into a
practice
[Music]